chase why just gotta be under lives
change organizations guy [ __ ]
organization change the world
ten years ago I set a goal to climb the
tallest mountain in the Western
Hemisphere and one of the tallest
mountains in the world
aconcagua its name just sounds insidious
rises to a height of 23,000 feet and is
located in a remote corner of the Andes
mountain range in Argentina a few months
ago I found myself on the GSB winter
break with a spare month to kill and
decided to go down to Argentina and
attempt to climb this mountain I got
there and Katie I was on that Ridgeline
I was climbing this thing I was on my
way up
every night I couldn't sleep because
winds were battering my tent every day I
could barely eat because the altitude
was diminishing my appetite and with
each step I could barely breathe on my
way up this mountain I got to within 700
meters of the summit I could see the
summit I could taste it I could
practically feel it but I could also
feel that I was too mentally and
physically exhausted to continue up the
mountain so I looked at the summit one
last time this goal that I had had for
10 years and I looked the other way and
I walked down the mountain I had failed
at something I had set out to intend to
achieve and when I came home I talked to
my dad about my experience my dad shares
my passion for the outdoors and he was
very much my inspiration for originally
spending time in the mountains and my
dad said well I'm really proud of you
Erin for making such a prudent decision
and turning around but surely you'll go
back next year and finish what you've
started now my dad is used to a fair
amount of
and attitude for me many of you are too
but he was really surprised by my answer
I turned to him and I said dad I am NOT
going back to that mountain I've been
there I've experienced it I'm more
concerned now about what's next
I believe that my response to my dad
isn't just about my failure and
ultimately success on aconcagua I think
it's emblematic of our generation I
believe that we are a generation of what
I call intrepid warriors 20-something
future leaders who are going to change
the world according to a unique and
nonlinear model that generations before
us don't fully understand my hope for
you today is that you'll join me in this
quest to be an intrepid warrior and that
you too
will realize that you can live an
aspirational and entrepreneurial life
that I believe my generation and bodies
we live according to a model the model
is to dream to start to endure to may be
fail to reflect and then to start over
for interrupted warriors the starting
line is truly more important than the
finish line
my dad's response to me wasn't all that
unusual like many of my peers here at
the GSB I do like to succeed
I am gold ribbon I am outcome driven but
my dad is very much a quintessential
baby boomer
he went to college where he studied
criminal justice then he became a police
officer he had four children he lives in
the suburbs he commutes to work he's
worked at one job his entire life and
he's actually set to retire this year I
am the quintessential sassy daughter of
the baby boomer I studied history in my
undergraduate
I then went and worked on Wall Street I
then decided Silicon Valley sounded
really cool so I decided to come to
business school have been at Stanford
for the past two years I think I'll
probably work for a company that makes
bicycles after I graduate I live with my
mother as an adult she loved it I'm
unmarried I envisioned 8 or 9
transformations before I'm finished on
this journey and I also don't think I'll
ever retire these are two models that
show the difference between myself and
my dad my dad the boomer is the model on
the left he pursues progress according
to a linear model step by step he
proceeds and he ultimately drives toward
what he's achieving by the small
incremental steps that lead him to that
finish line it's been very successful
for him and I admire him I and many of
you in the audience are the model on the
right we are a scattershot approach we
try everything we throw things up
against the wall and Steve sees what
sticks and we are fundamentally unafraid
of what happens between when we sort of
launch that point and throw it up
against the wall it's a scatter shot
there are successes there are failures
there are starting lines there are
finish lines but what's happening that I
don't think maybe some older generations
fully appreciate is that the trend line
on that scatterplot is trending upward
and time will tell which model is a more
successful path to progress but I
believe we're on to something and I
think the scattershot approach is going
to lead to the slope of our line as a
generation being one of the greatest
that the world has ever seen so let's
unpack the scatter shot a little bit and
let's understand what's behind this
model that causes us to fail succeed try
again and enable progress through this
unconventional
method the first step for me has been in
the dream I told you about how long I've
dreamed of aconcagua and read books
about it and studied it online and
finally found myself there a few months
ago but I dreamed for a long time and as
I dreamed I wrote things down and now
years later I have this really really
long list a spreadsheet of many
different dreams that I have I may
achieve some of them I may not many of
you aspire to start companies to meet
new people to climb new mountains to
meet new families to recycle regardless
of what that is in the dream stage by
writing it down it brings us to the next
stage this is the number one most
important stage of this entire model if
you leave this room today with one thing
I want you to leave with the word start
in your mind this is what our generation
of habits we inhabit this starting line
this unabashedly POG wa I didn't know
what was gonna happen
I hoped what might happen but when I got
to that starting line I was just as
blind as I had ever been going into
something but I found that by being
there I started putting one step in
front of the other and that leads to the
indoor phase starting things is hard
there is no question about it and I
think my dad finds comfort in being
along a linear line because he knows
what each step looks like on that
journey that would be incredibly boring
to me I find comfort and having a lot of
little bits along the way and I take
comfort in having done them before
endurance is enabled by peers I was on
aconcagua with a classmate and friend
and it's also enabled by having started
before it gets easier as it goes the
next stage is in brackets because it's
the failure stage
we hope the failure stage doesn't happen
but sometimes it does and as a
generation we're not afraid of this
happening I have a sneaky suspicion that
my dad is actually a little bit afraid
of failure I don't want to fail but I've
experienced it and I've also experienced
some great successes that have come out
of it when I came back from aconcagua I
feel incredibly prepared to do a future
expedition I made a great friend I
experienced a new culture
so I was able to find tremendous
successes in something that objectively
I still consider a failure the last
stage of the model is something my dad
does really well and something as a
generation we really don't and that's
the reflection phase there's a reason
why the model has white space between
each of the areas and that's because
sometimes we just don't stop
we're on computers or were on phones and
we fail to fully appreciate the
experience that we just had so part of
what I did after aconcagua was walk down
the mountain mostly because I had to but
it took three days and it gave me a
tremendous opportunity to think about
what happened and to more importantly
think about what I would be taking away
from this experience to future endeavors
and the final stage is just to start
over when my dad looks at this model he
sees something like a washing machine
that just goes around and around the
room and never stops when I look at the
model I see something that goes around
and around and around but is actually a
wheel that's moving us forward toward
future progress so when I think about
aconcagua I don't think about going back
why would I go back to aconcagua when is
katie pointed out now neveress exists
I'm not sure I will summit on Everest
but I'm very sure that I can start
and my challenge to all of you today is
to find that part of your lives where
you can be an intrepid warrior we're
instead of going back and doing
something that you've done before find
the courage that I know that you have to
start something new